chutzpah hahaha that was an interesting
laugh to do during a broadcast but I
appreciate your energy oh yeah nice hair
that's very nice Here I am so excited
for them to see what we did with to Rico
welcome to Sims and left gonna be pretty
awesome dude wasn't it yes it was it was
special like tarik Cohen what a good
sport
Oh for one just stick around you're
gonna love it yes the thing that
captured everybody's attention this
weekend though wasn't even the games it
was Lil Wayne and Odell Beckham hanging
out with the players reporter Joe Xena
Anderson and Odell taking a truth serum
and talking about Eli Manning here's a
little bit of what he said he's not
gonna get out the party but he's it a
matter of time as you can can you still
do it yeah he's being pretty safe we
have been saying this for three years
yes we've been trying to keep it real
but I know Dell does it it kind of goes
wrong yes it's as though he was in the
movie liar liar a favorite of us to the
pen is bra bra bra bra royal blue so we
wondered what if all NFL players had to
tell the truth all right I'm gonna go
first Jerry Jones to Jason Garrett
afterwards he said you know we got to
risk it there Jason's still standing by
him what he really wanted to say is hey
hey Jason leaned in real close you know
the millions I'm spent on that olan and
you're going to punt I'm about to punt
you back to Princeton and you come with
that nonsense one more time I got day ik
I got Zeke I'm about to called is and
let him yell in your face if that's
gonna help you but I got a problem with
you JG working on my ex that's pretty
good I like it I was down to Texas
before oh okay Ramsey to bortles
Oh little bromance here Jalen Ramsey
congratulating Blake bortles but what
he's really saying is hey Blake just
don't go interceptions don't even care
about incompletions go out for the day
doesn't matter you're obviously a little
off target today cuz you missed me on
our high five handshake there you're a
little off there but as long as you
don't turn it over we can win the game
even without you all right next one Matt
Ryan
dan Quinn Matt Ryan sand Dan let's
figure this defense out catch up what he
really wants to say is hey Danny Boy I
put up 90 points the last three games
and it doesn't matter cuz you've allowed
a hundred and twenty-one your defense
stinks you've lost all these players and
you're still running the same scheme
you're a defensive coach can I get some
help please I get some creativity please
please all right now we got the greatest
of all time yeah hey rod you know he's
trying to console' this kicker a guy
went overboard field goals in a missed
extra point but you know what he really
wanted to say left go come over here
don't flinch it's okay what do you want
to say don't say oh you have nice hair
that's very nice here any wants to go
are you kidding me dude I mean what's up
I carry this team for 10 years straight
I'm out here playing on one leg all you
gotta do is kick the [ __ ] ball
between the two yellow sticks you do
that again you're out of here
I will tell McCarthy to cut you in three
seconds so if we have to be honest right
now because we talked about Jim Carrey
earlier I would like to admit to all of
you this is an honest take I believe
that Ace Ventura 2 when nature calls is
one of the five greatest movies of all
time oh my gosh that is just beyond
stupid I don't I know you guys agree
with me
fill the comments section below it's not
even the best Ace Ventura movie I mean
that's what's hilarious why because one
has Dan Marino and a dog that was it
that's exactly right who is in a jungle
Oh white bat whoa we had guano balls
nothing funny the whole movie that is a
magic glove which came from one note I
was into oh this is a lovely room of
death right but like a club came from
one listen yeah we all came from
somewhere and I thought what a reek
Cohen came from a Jewish background boy
was I wrong so what I wanted to do with
tarik Cohen was to share my Jewish
culture and experience with him it's
kind of a bear mitzvah enjoy tarik
Cohen's come in New York to eat at a
Jewish deli with Simpson Lefko oh they
[Music]
when I heard there was a guy in the NFL
Sims named Tariq : yeah I said Wow
Khayyam we've got ourselves and finally
a Jewish running back and then I found
out not only have you never been to a
Bar Mitzvah
not only have you ever had Jewish food
you're not Jewish
sadly no sadly I appreciate the side :
though I mean that's in the Mount
Rushmore of Jewishness it really is I am
a hundred percent Jewish yeah what I
want to give to you is the full Jewish
experience I can call it a Jewish
combine to making you feel like a true
Jewish man are you ready to take this
journey with me oh yeah I'm definitely
ready okay
[Music]
this is our first dish this is a
customary Jewish breakfast do you want
to take a guess as to what is in front
of you right now sushi sushi
it is not sushi in a smoked salmon the
Eternity the fish exactly man yes man
that's right all right so don't be
afraid of it
no I'm not so why don't you pick it up
oh that was a oh my god hold on don't
like you don't do you mind if I have a
bite you have all the mice okay I mean
it's perfect this is a Jewish deli
staple and it's not just what it is
this is a pastrami on rye and do you see
how much meat is on there yeah excessive
okay Miffy he looked at that leg it was
a blitzing linebacker when it came in he
like literally looked at it it was like
why don't you bite into that sorry on
the foots woman mm-hmm and this is part
of the process to the strategy of how to
bite the eye I could see that I'm going
to try to flatten him nice I think he's
gonna like this they like already
confident about it I really give him
credit for having the guts to just dive
in there though wise little cheese
nothing on me no cheese mayonnaise or
something well that wouldn't be kosher
we have one more this is the Cadillac of
Jewish food tarik Cohen I'd like to
introduce you to your new favorite food
matzo ball soup matzo ball matzo ball
have you heard of matzo balls before
mozzarella mozzarella not the same I
guess it's not cheese there's no cheese
in there there's no cheese you thought
matzo balls had cheese - I totally did
so the best way to do this is to take
your spoon take a little piece of the
matzo ball get a little bit of soup in
there oh it though it's very soft and
there it is okay good
that's the test my chicken noodle soup
really it's chicken noodle soup
the second part of our Jewish combine is
Jewish slack no not only do I want you
to eat like a Jew I want you to talk
like a Jew so here's the first word this
is gonna be fun it is smooth
schmooze what do you think Moo's means
good sleep good sleep Oh like I should
marry those two moves i'ma go smooth so
mousse is actually to like kind of talk
somebody up hey I like your play calls
madnikey that's a real bit of all
unusual move all your moves you win
right next word whoo good luck saying
this one shoot spa good spot good
all right gotta get how we were in the
team meeting and Tariq Cohen stood up
and said I don't like that play Tariq's
got a lot of hutzpah like mouth yeah
exactly
this is the Jewish slang phrase of all
generations we've a boy Vey what do you
think it is tarik Cohen was supposed to
run the slant route and he ran the go
rod boy a vet to recon or it's like all
those pickles for me
boy they oh yeah guys you thought both
is a good a man it could be everything
yeah that's the one I may use right
there you have ace the Jewish combine
and I have a gift for you Oh baby
wait vague I give you a Chicago Bears
yarmulke Jewish petechiae a Jewish
fitted cap yes oh my gosh it looks so
beautiful you're not out of here oh I
like it put that bad boy on yeah and I
have an Eagles yarmulke now we celebrate
let's do it up for
[Applause]
tarik cohen buddy
lehayim boy they boy they indeed Tariq
is an amazing dude and there is a thing
of professional athletes going to Bar
Mitzvahs we talked to Tariq game a
little nudge-nudge he could be down
right so if you're in Chicago and you're
having a bar mitzvah
why don't you turn that into a bear
mitzvah tweet at Tariq he knows the
tweets are coming and maybe just maybe
Coen is showing up to your Bar Mitzvah
what's up I'm Matt Forte and you're
watching Sims and left code
[Music]
hello and welcome football fans it is
Thursday night and welcome to mediocre
MetLife Stadium I and the incomparable
Adam Lefko and I am representing the
Eagles on Homer cast
I am a self-made man that is now a
champion and I'd like to introduce you
to my subpar co-host who got this job
because of his father hey Chris hey
Thank You loser Philadelphia announcer
who thinks a lot of himself but hey
let's not forget I wouldn't expect it
anything less from a group of fans that
throw batteries at Santa Claus and gosh
have a courtroom in the bottom of their
stadium Kumud you're gonna bag on our
stadium ok Philadelphia doesn't mean
brotherly love in this telecast it
doesn't it's about law and order and I
think that Eli's play has been criminal
thus far I mean how can you defend a guy
whose pants constantly smell like poop
at the fear of a password - speaking of
poop don't your fans eat it once you
guys win once every 40 to 50 years great
organization speaking of eating it you
guys have been eating l60 in the last 20
times you've played the Eagles you lost
talked about the history books there pal
oh that's ok we don't really care close
the yearbook that's this year and you
got one more win than us and you're the
Superbowl defending champions ha ha ha
that was an interesting laugh to do
touring a broadcast but I appreciate
your energy keys to the game what are
you doing for a Giants miracle win
seeing as how all of the hope for this
season is long Wow we have exciting
offensive weapons and a future to look
forward to with Odell Beckham jr. and
say qualm barkley that's what we're
looking forward to you guys right now
are just a disappointing underperforming
team that thinks Rocky's real in
Philadelphia sorry Philly it's a made-up
character rocky okay I think we can
agree on one thing though screw Dallas
as you can see Eagles Giants means a lot
to Simms in love go and super steve is
back he nailed the Patriots last week
this week is he siding with Simms is he
siding with me let's go to Central Park
and find out guess who won
super Steve 1 not Scuba Steve you got a
shout-out for sim no slims I know you
love Big Daddy I'm gonna take you on a
tour and show you all Big Daddy stuff
all right so I got into envelope 1 1905
you wanna handle that Central Park if
you don't live in New York I can
understand
so congratulations thank you absolutely
appreciate on Thursday night my Eagles
against slims as Giants Eagles are
favored by three in New York take me
through you know how I love you you know
how I feel about slims yes that being
said I have to go at the Giants taking
the points at home why do you say you
have to
they've lost more they're at home and I
just I feel good about the home team
this week do you see the calmness in his
eyes do you see the focus do you feel
confident I do you often get slims on
the next tour he needs to get out here
yeah show his face in person out here
super Steve going Giants at home plus 3
what do you think slim so Scuba Steve I
think I'm gonna go with the negative
ghostrider I'm going with the Eagles
you're taking an away team huh he
doesn't lost you know call me crazy
you're going with my eagle yep I can't
go with him now that he called me slim
so you're only picking the Eagles
because of super Steve no I really think
that but scuba Steve's wrong anyways man
another rivalry we'll see if super Steve
is back Sunday night Chiefs Patriots and
another game of the year for Patrick
opposing to the Patriots run the clock
down or do they battle it out with
mahomes and a shooter I think the first
thing I thought of is well they'll try
to run the ball and keep my homes and
the Kansas City Chiefs offense on the
sidelines but this is New England and I
still think at the end of the day
they're gonna go our strength is our
offensive passing game are all our
schemes Edelman Grunk Chris Hogan
Dorsett put Brady in the shotgun and let
him just dissect yeah and I think that's
what they're gonna do and let's not
forget if anybody's proven to us that
they can go on 10 play drives
consistently just throwing the football
it's the New England Patriots wins the
game I
I'm gonna go Kansas City but it's a good
one yeah it's gonna be it's gonna be an
awesome game but I'm going Chiefs when
you're watching the game of Sunday night
before the game tuning a little early
this mug
yes Chris freakin Sims company is good
be on the pregame show he's got them
fooled I'll tell you what bamboozled
yeah but take a pic
sure of them let's create some memes
when he's like this or when he's like
that we're gonna post some pictures
let's get the meme factory go and Sims
memes Sunday pregame be there or be
square
first Sims peace out homey yo holla
holla holla holla at you later enjoy the
games are you coming home for
Thanksgiving I'm not gonna be able to
you know we have a game you know your
grandmother doesn't have many
Thanksgivings left to wreak a knocking
fear afterwards it might be late but I
guess here afterwards I love you and I
just hope one day you can understand I
love you too
hey what's up homies thanks for watching
subscribe to the be our YouTube channel
man you're such a millennial also while
you're here we have a lot other videos
check them out and then what time does
our show come out Wednesday 8:00 p.m. be
there or be square
he ruined it it was really close